also leute die hütte brennt in einer
woche haben eine hammer kooperation
müssen uns neuen partner vorstellen
da muss ich brauch richtig geniale idee
und debug dahinten verstehst du was
richtig genial ist muss durch die decke
gehen
wir müssen endlich selber brennen um das
von anderen zu entfachen
sarah macht man lässt schon etliche
[Musik]
ciao ciao
da
jan o
eine person waghäusel ist gelandet
[Musik]
danke danke stadt in nordrhein westfalen
gehen rein und holen uns die rezepte ist
unterwegs
das passiert lassen wir die person
mission zu haben uns verstanden
[Musik]
sag mal wie blöd kann man sein
wahrscheinlich reingekommen das kaufen
kann man sein recht jetzt rein jetzt ab
ob man das hat nicht funktioniert
wir brauchen und was anderes wir wollen
andere geniale idee
was ist da los war es hat im osten hat
für dieses mal kann
wir brauchen die geniale idee es hat
nicht funktioniert
die musik passt
[Musik]
keine undercover flex doch all die
anderen lagen glas zu füßen
aker basis jetzt übertreibt die lage
nicht hier süßen unter neuer provokant
für seine frische sätze neue standards
in der küche schon seit jahren die
vielfalt die auswahl so was kannst du
dich ausmalen hat neue partner heute was
geht ab leute sagt rose und dieser
leiste und die company einfach lustig
und dieser lifestyle des schicksale und
die company einfach nur produkte könnte
vielleicht auch gut aussehen ich
probier's mal erst ok major stu films
noch keine undercover fleck das ist auch
nichts dann lassen wir es lieber gleich
bleiben
hört nämlich hammer wie wär's mit
influenza dies wertete neuen situation
und zur feier des tages gibt es mit dem
kot joschi 20 prozent auf alles außer
tiernahrung schaut unbedingt vorbei
schaut dort an dieser stelle an meine
freundin celine an oder schreibt hoch
schaut euch die sachen an die kahlo
größte was ich habe das ist auch nicht
das richtige also sally daran denkst du
auch was ich denke
[Musik]
willst du käsekuchen backen
wir brauchen quack wie sieht die bag
abteilung auch das ist ein cloud sind es
nicht alleine schaffen
wichtig für menschen
wir packen diese kuchen und laden
wir brauchen auch noch ein glückliches
die königin und ihre prinzessinnen raus
stopp wirklich aussieht schneemann und
elsa anna-carina sabrina und außerdem
der 11 der sieht komisch aus ich möchte
mich nichts zu tun
das glauben wir uns schneller gefallen
aber morath ganz ehrlich wenn ich schon
jetzt singen und tanzen darf dann lassen
wir es einfach wir machen das was am
besten zu uns passt ich bin keine
schauspielerin keine tänzerinnen und
auch keine hieb oberin da machen wir
doch dass und bleiben so wie ich bin
ich kann kochen backen haushaltstipps
geben und das alles möchte ich mit euch
teilen
[Musik]
hey was soll ich noch mal mitbringen
ja frisch oder also scheffel
hallo herr ich dir was helfen suchst du
was bestimmte ja ich will für meine
enkeltochter eine geburtstagstorte
brauchen habe keine ahnung was wie wäre
es mit einem schoko boden und nah
vanillecreme im prinzip könnt ihr beides
machen also wenn ihr auskochen wollt
habt doch vorher die gemüseabteilung
können frisches gemüse nehmen oder wenn
ihr sagt wegen dem nachwuchs haben wir
nichts die zeit da könnte auch gern tief
gefrorenes gemüse nehmen also da braucht
auch keine sorge haben
es wird ja alles erntefrisch tief
gefroren hat noch an nährstoffe und
vitamine und ihr habt ein bisschen zeit
für euch bio-eier hast du ja das ist
schon mal perfekt und ich würde sagen
gut man ihm doch einfach den bug auf für
den teig der software trade und darin
immer drauf super ich danke dir richtig
schön viel spaß beim fahren wenn du
magst an ihm doch einfach ihr bier
zitronen die sind unbehandelt da kannst
du die schale benutzen zum beispiel für
zitronenkuchen kanzlerin saft auspressen
und am ende die ausgedrückte zitrone
noch als spülmaschinen dem mega hätte
ich mir auf jeden fall
und genau so machen wir es jetzt ab dem
15 märz gibt es jede woche ein neues
rezept von mir auf nebel kochen.de ich
werde fürs kochen und backen meine
erfahrungen und tipps mit euch teilen
und ich würde sagen wir gestalten
gemeinsam die liebe community ich freue
mich schon richtig auf euch ich habe
übrigens noch einen weiteren song aber
ich darf ihn nicht singen der schneemann
der flip rechts und daraus
entweder man holt die leute müssen das
jetzt jeder volleyball mädels rezepte
klar ist so blöd wie du ja ok
also jetzt ist die katze aus dem sack
die überraschung ist verkündet ich hoffe
dass wir euch wirklich gefallen wir uns
richtig genüge
ja also wir wollten im prinzip euch
mitteilen aber ich glaube jetzt habt ihr
es mittlerweile auch mitbekommen
auch der mini dass wir eine
partnerschaft mit lidl haben und
wahrscheinlich fragt ihr euch jetzt ja
wie kam es denn dazu
ihr wisst ja dass wir die letzten jahre
um genau zu sein so 15 jahre mit globus
eine partnerschaft hatten und das war
auch wirklich eine freundschaftliche
partnerschaft folglich wohl auch alle
recht gut ich muss auch sagen dort hat
damals auch alles mit dennis angefangen
wenn man da den dennis kennengelernt der
mittlerweile bei uns im team ist und es
war einfach eine partnerschaft auf
augenhöhe und da gab es einfach alle
zwei wochen ein neues rezept von mir die
rezept karte gab es dann beim globus und
im prinzip kommt man dahin die rezepte
holen
die zutaten holen und im prinzip einfach
alle rezepte nachkochen und nach backen
und diese mit der community teilen
der einzige nachteil muss ich sagen war
einfach dass der globus relativ
beschränkt ist bei uns genau der ist
praktisch eben in süddeutschland eher
vertreten und viele aus dem norden die
wussten nicht mal aus der glaube es war
viel haben gedacht zum baumarkt und es
war einfach so dass auch schon die
rezeptkarten dies ja auch kostenlos dort
zu sammeln gab mit rezept ordner
die wurden auch schon teilweise online
gehandelt also da haben wirklich
zuschauer die eben das glück hatten
ebenso ein globus zu wohnen haben sich
dann die karten geholt die dann online
gestellt und verkauft und da habe ich
schon immer gesagt eigentlich total
unfair denn die karten die kosten nichts
die geben wir kostenlos für euch raus
und das wollte ich natürlich nicht und
mit der zeit sind wir eben auch
gewachsen und haben uns eben gedacht wir
brauchen einen partner der eben auch
groß genug ist und vor allem der überall
vertreten ist so dass wir rezepte machen
können oder auch mal signierstunden
machen können oder events machen können
jan im prinzip haben wir eigentlich gar
nicht so lange überlegen müssen
für uns war es einfach wichtig dass wir
einen partner haben der vielleicht auch
gar nicht so weit weg von uns ist also
auch recht in unserer region ist und
dann kam einfach die idee mit dem lidl
muss auch sagen my coverage von uns sind
keine halbe stunde
ja denn im prinzip also wenn man eine
partnerschaft hat finde ich doch immer
ganz wichtig dass man zum einen auf
augenhöhe ist dass man kurze wege hat
dass man gut miteinander kommuniziert
und dass das ganze auch recht
freundschaftlich ist und ich finde dass
die kooperation oder die die
partnerschaft jetzt echt gut ist ja und
das wäre einfach jetzt in starken
partner an der seite haben der wird auch
stark genug ist überall vertreten ist
und auch da planen wir in zukunft die
rezeptkarten zu drucken aber natürlich
muss das ganze jetzt erstmal anfangen
und wir haben jetzt die ersten videos
auch schon gedreht die rezept videos und
eigentlich verändert sich für euch gar
nichts außer dass wir ganz nah sind wir
ganz genau und wie gesagt über den
ganzen deutschland in den
deutschlandweite aktionen in österreich
ganz cool so hinterfragt genau und ist
auch das coole daran dass man halt dass
das nicht alles schwarz oder weiß ist
sondern auch dass zwischen drin was ist
und er stellt coole geschichte ja ja und
jetzt weg sagt anna damit gestartet und
wollten euch einfach mit diesem video
das ganze verkünden weil ich sagte komm
jetzt einfach hier auf die couch setzen
und sagen hey wir schaden jetzt eine
kooperation war irgendwie doch das wahre
und deswegen haben wir uns im team eben
wird sie wirklich sehr kurzfristig
überlegt was wir machen wollen und dann
entstand innerhalb von vier tagen
die idee zu diesem großen spot und die
haben auch gesagt augenhöhe heißt auch
immer das nicht etwas gezwungen was
mache ich nicht ist uns ja also meine
frau ist jetzt so wie es andere sicher
kein influenza also wenn jetzt zb sowas
zum beispiel seite dieses ding benutze
hat sich mein leben komplett verändert
entschuldigung denn dubai hintergrund
dass irgendwo hintergrund also ein super
jahr gedacht das ist alles ja so sie mir
dieses wissen selber und so werden auch
nicht sein und in schubladen lässt sich
auch nicht stecken einfach so sein wie
wir sind und deswegen haben wir das
video gemacht wie wir sind ja genau und
haben wir ja auch
tv spot fürs fernsehen gemacht und dann
an dem gleichen tag haben wir
entschlossen wir machen für unseren
kanal ganz eigenen spot und eigentlich
also ganz liebe grüße gehen auch als
little team raus denn auch das lied team
hat den spot gerade eben mit euch zum
ersten mal bei der abnahme kein gar
könnt ihr sehen wollt macht einfach sehr
wohl so könnte sich so ergeben ich weiß
was ich normalerweise kein ärger
fertigungsanlage oder du für deine
netflix anlage haben wir kunden auch
irgendwie fürs ganze team
jeder konnte sich selbst verwirklichen
also ich weiß von meiner frau ich mag es
nicht so sie magst darf ich jedes lidl
rezept jetzt als prinzessin einlassen
nicht so und lasst uns mehr singen das
war's jetzt lässt sich mal genau denn
ich wollte schon mal daran seine rap
einlagen gemacht der coach der wohl
schönsten richtig kann man künstler
wir wollten immer schon den netflix
serie drehen irgendwann werden wir es
auch machen und auf diesem niveau drehen
hatte hat auch cool gemacht allein die
kamera die über 100.000 euro kosten wir
gedreht haben haben uns ausleihen müssen
das ganze kriegt man der unterwasser
hersteller in der region oder halb voll
als vor ort allerdings sind den sprint
auf zur verfügung gestellt also es war
eine richtig coole produktion und
wirklich sehr kurzweilig durch den
überfall machen die bühne durfte man
redet ihr kostüm anziehen
da kann wirklich nicht sagen ja in jeder
szene von volkan vorbei haus des geldes
der professor sein
wir sagen auch immer professionell eine
tolle ideen hat und wir uns warum
scheucht ich hab ich mich vor jetzt und
deswegen haben wir uns gedacht machen
wir eben diesen spot und planen denn
jetzt hier heute auf 20 15
und ich hoffe dass er euch ich denke er
hat euch selber rascht denn es ist
einfach mal was ganz anderes gewesen
aber eben doch wir allerdings immer
schon quatsch köpfe war es noch nicht
immer aber es wird immer ums rezepten
ist es wichtig so wird bei lidl auch
sagen viele rezepte ein paar hintergrund
ein bisschen hintergrundwissen kommt es
von dir zu dem produkt neue leider nicht
ja ich habe mir nämlich gedacht dass wir
einfach jede woche ein rezept machen und
dann werde ich im wechsel mal kochen
backen nicht meinen vielleicht kommen
zwei park konzept und zwei kochrezepte
das schauen wir dann einfach und ihr
dürft auch wirklich die rezepte mit
gestalten schreibt mir gerne was ihr
sehen möchte was euch vielleicht noch
fehlt und ich freue mich auch drauf wenn
die zukunft denn die rezeptkarten
erhältlich sind
und ich würde sagen wir zeigen euch
noch ein bisschen was vom 3 was so
hinter den kulissen passiert ist denn
ich muss sagen wir haben drei tage lang
unser haus auf den kopf gestellt silicon
valley auf den kopf gestellt hat spaß
und die lidl-filiale auf den kopf
gestellt die eremitage in waghäusel auf
den kopf gestellt und dem hof ist im rat
ungefähr 30 mal ungelogen über die mauer
gefallen als halterung flecken nein ich
bin gut gepolstert wollte es jetzt hören
ja wolltest du sachen nichts wird hatte
ich schon mal überlegt warum ich noch
nie auf dem bild bauchfrei war das mal
überlegt main statt blauer flecken
herrscht genau das ist es trotzdem 1000
tausend dank das video angeschaut hab ja
und ich hoffe wir können weiterhin so
lustige dinge machen die hinein aber
auch mal zum nachdenken wer also
schranke schreibt uns einfach mal wie
also schreibt uns einfach euer feedback
ob wir mal so eine richtige serie drehen
soll also mit verfolgungsjagd und wenn
ihr lust hat können wir jetzt auch gerne
schon bei lidl de vorbeischauen als
einfach auf dem youtube-kanal instagram
account und abonnieren
nachdem bastian verpasste ja auch nicht
das allererste video
ich freue mich schon jetzt noch schöner
abend
demnächst bin ich bei euch in ganz
deutschland also auch im haus drin sind
vorbei sondern von jahren aufsteller
machen ja aber ich komme doch die tür
versprochen in lebensgröße ja war das
wieder so
die seiten nein der ob von dir ein
lebensgroßer aufsteller bei einem
wirklich nicht sein
die hofstatt singe ich bitte wirklich
ich will nicht dass alle zuschauer
verlieren
danke
gehört
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
berlin dpa
[Musik]
nein
in olfen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich habe vor aus juni an mobistar zu
machen
aber der typ kann höchst eine
wasserleiche sport und spiel sowie
aufgedunsen mit der ist
[Musik]
bis in drei tagen alle mitgearbeitet
haben unser eigenes team das team oder
zugekommen ist wahnsinn hat auch richtig
spaß gemacht und ich habe unglaublich
wir sehen hier wird der wahnsinn sein
ist wirklich schon auf dem netflix
niveau gigantisch ich danke euch allen
[Musik]